bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 29 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
votre actualité locale avec nos invités
mais également les journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de
cette édition la réforme du code de la
route n'est pas du goût des auto-écoles
à l'appel du conseil national des
professions de l'automobile
elles ont manifesté aujourd'hui partout
en france le modem soit 118 veut
impulser une nouvelle dynamique et se
rajeunir son nouveau délégué
départemental jean baptiste à monique 23
ans est notre invité ce soir pour nous
en parler
et en football américain ont joué ce
week-end la troisième journée du
championnat élite l'équivalent de la
première division
ce samedi les templiers d'elancourt ont
été battus sur leur terrain par les
dauphins de nice
retour sur le match à suivre et une
journée de mobilisation pour les
professionnels de la conduite à l'appel
du conseil national des professions de
l'automobile le cnp à environ 2000 auto
écoles ont manifesté depuis ce matin en
bloquant les routes de lyon toulouse
angers est bien évidemment paris en
cause la réforme du code de la route
prévue par la loi macron qui devrait
être âpre y est appliqué par don dès la
mi-avril bien trop tôt selon le cnp a
les détails avec camille lambert
c'est une première depuis 1998
l'examen du code de la route à faire
peau neuve présenté il ya quelques mois
par le ministère de l'intérieur la
réforme prévoit de passer de 700 à 1000
questions mais surtout de réduire les
délais du passage du permis en
privatisant l'examen du code on améliore
la qualité on diminue les délais et les
candidats sont sept satisfait ça ne ça
ne pénalise pas les inspecteurs en place
en dévalorisant leurs actions et nous
les directeurs d'écoles de conduite
entretenons des relations plus apaisées
avec nos candidats boîte automatique et
nouvelles technologies les questions se
veulent plus moderne le remplacement des
anciennes question est prévue pour le 18
avril bien trop tôt selon le conseil
national des professions de l'automobile
lundi 29 février le syndicat a appelé
les auto-écoles à magnifique
c'est dans la rue elles étaient près de
1000 dans la capitale que durer tant ces
deux mois avant le bac on changeait de
l'épreuve
on est fiers de nos élèves on est fiers
de leur forme à turin et on les défend
aso il faut avoir un juste prix et pour
sa demande dans que cette réforme est
une réforme ne puis débuté en 14
selon le cnp a il faut en moyenne quatre
mois pour former un candidat au code de
la route
mais sur cette mobilisation le principal
syndicat de la profession fait cavalier
seul
les organisations unique et une idec se
sont félicités de cette réforme et n'ont
pas pris part à la manifestation et le
cndd a été reçue en début d'après-midi
par le cabinet du ministère de
l'intérieur ils ont obtenu un délai de
deux semaines le remplacement des
anciennes question serait donc prévu
pour début mai le syndicat ne veut
toujours pas ce délai suffisant et
indique qu'il maintiendra la pression
sur les pouvoirs publics et nous ouvrons
donc une page politique à présent
invités de ce journal dans un instant
jean baptiste à monique délégué
départemental du modem
mais pour le moment nous faisons le
point sur la législative partielle dans
la 12e circonscription des yvelines avec
vous il faut un bon soir bonsoir bonsoir
florane 13 et 20 mars ce sont deux dates
à retenir pour les électeurs de cette 2e
circonscription des yvelines si vous
résidez à vélizy villacoublay dans une
partie de versailles ou encore dans le
canton de chevreuse qui comprend magny
les hameaux voisins le bretonneux pour
saint quentin en yvelines
il faudra vous rendre aux yeux de votre
député valérie pécresse ayant fait le
choix de démissionner valérie pécresse
devenu président de la région
ile-de-france attia fait donc le choix
d'écouter l'assemblée et pourtant la loi
ne l'y obligé pas aujourd'hui un
parlementaire peut exercer au maximum un
mandat dans une assemblée locales
régions départements communes david
douillet lui aussi élu conseiller
régional en ile de france a d'ailleurs
fait le choix de rester et député de sa
12e circonscription en revanche
impossible pour benoît hamon le député
socialiste de la 10e circonscription de
prendre un poste à la région en en
conservant un autre dans une mairie
c'est pourquoi il n'est plus conseiller
municipal à trappes
pour en revenir à valérie pécresse
comment son départ est il perçu elle qui
a été élue pour la première fois en 2002
voici vos réponses au micro de camille
lambert
oui elle a eu raison absolument pas trop
si elle s'est engagée il ya pas
longtemps plus qu'elle est
c'est lui donc c'est un peu c'est un peu
gênant enfin bon je suis d'accord avec
ces démissions puisque je suis contre le
cumul des mandats
enfin j'étais un peu déçu parce que
j'aime beaucoup valérie pécresse c'est
quelque chose ne pas habituel pour la
région parisienne et je trouve ça très
très bien rousseau normal c'est son
engagement et le cumul des mandats
ne me convient pas non plus a
normalement le double mandat ça devrait
être annulée puis il entend donc ma foi
ça peut être bien elle se concentrera
beaucoup plus sur une mission que sur
plusieurs et maintenant que valérie
pécresse est parti pour lui succéder
ils sont aujourd'hui 9 à se présenter
avec leurs suppléants tous leurs
suppléants la liste va apparaître à
l'écran et on remarque que la droite a
fait l'union autour de pascal thévenot
c'est le maire de vélizy là le soutien
de son parti les républicains mais aussi
de lui dit et du modem en revanche à
gauche le ps part seul avec tristan
jacques jeune candidat de 28 ans adjoint
au maire de magny les hameaux parti
communiste europe ecologie selon ce
chacun de leurs côtés dans la campagne
d'infos conditions ça sera difficile
pour la gauche et d'imaginer l'emporter
d'autant plus difficile que la
circonscription était déjà à droite dans
les années 80 avec franck borotra en
figures fortes qui a au dc a d'ailleurs
siéger en tant que président du conseil
départemental et puis vous l'avez aussi
sans doute remarqué mais à gauche il ya
de nombreuses petites candidatures qui
viendra enlever de précieuses voix comme
celle de nouvelle donne par exemple un
mouvement politique né au sein du parti
socialiste en 2014
cependant il ya aussi quelques
candidatures divergentes à droite didier
blanchard candidats nous citoyens il
siège à vélizy dans l'opposition
également il reproche à pascal thévenot
de déjà cumulé des mandats maire de la
ville vice-président de la communauté
d'agglomération versailles grand parc
par exemple florane votre invité pour le
journal jean baptiste à monique bonsoir
vous êtes le délégué du modem 78 et vous
soutenez pascal thévenot
j'ai tout de même envie de vous demander
ce que vous pensez de cette situation
est plus particulièrement de ce cumul
des mandats si jamais demain pascal
thévenot devenez députés déjà il faut
remettre les choses un peu en
perspective
il faut déjà comprendre que c'est une
législative partielle dont qui a pour
but on va dire de finir la mandature en
cours donc c'est un mandat d'un an
il reste un an pour pour le député qui
sera élu oui aujourd'hui si on a
justement cet adjectif cette législative
partielle c'est parce que valérie
pécresse a décidé de se mettre en
conformité avec son engagement de
campagne de ne pas cumuler le mandat de
présidente de région et le mandat de
député donc c'est tout à son honneur
nous la cause justement du non cumul des
mandats est une cause très importante
pour le mouvement démocrate donc nous
allons justement cette position même si
pascal thévenot lui ce sera un choix qui
lui appartiendra on n'a pas à se
prononcer sur sur son hub redonner sa
candidat mais nous sommes
tout à fait son cadet en tueur on est
persuadé que pascal thévenot sera
candidat de consensus et qu'il arrivera
à rassembler les centristes les
républicains pour cette élection flore
en avant de vous laisser avec votre
invité un dernier mot deux derniers mots
sur ce scrutin législatif dans la 2e
circonscription en 2012 valérie pécresse
avait totalisé plus de 40 6% des voix au
premier tour
presque 50 9% au second sous l'étiquette
ump uniquement le ps était au premier
tour à 30 5% et le front national
troisième avec 8,5 pour cent qu'elle
sera donc le score à de l'extrême droite
cette fois ci la dernière fois que les
électeurs se sont exprimés c'était lors
de la campagne des départementales en
2015 le parti de marine le pen sur la
ville même de vélizy était presque à 23%
et puis la seconde chose c'est que mardi
prochain pour le 7-8 politique à 18h30
nous organiserons un débat avec les neuf
listes qui seront conviés sur ce plateau
les neuf candidats qui viendront et
débattre de leurs programmes
merci wilfried sanou nous manquons pas
de regarder justement ces programmes
d'après le journal puis ça ferait
journal voilà à suivre et nous
continuons avec vous jean baptiste à
mo'nique pour parler justement du modem
vous êtes il provient vous avez 23 ans
c'est assez jeune pour être un délai d
télétravail comment vous expliquez votre
nomination
bon je pense qu'il ya deux choses on
entend énormément les partis politiques
parler de renouvellement notamment nous
renouveler la classe politique renouvelé
les militants sûr on va dire des
fonctions un peu dirigeante
nous avons fait le choix de le faire
aujourd'hui il y avait eu lieu un parti
qui le faisait c'était le front national
on a vu beaucoup de jeunes montés au
front national nous c'est vraiment une
volonté justement de faire émerger des
jeunes en politique pourquoi je pense
qu'il ya deux raisons principales à ça
la première c'est d'apporter un peu de
fraîcheur notamment dans les idées avec
des débats aujourd'hui comme le
numérique ou l'école l'économie
collaboratif je pense que les jeunes ont
beaucoup apporté sur ces sujets là et
puis pour on va dire impulser une
nouvelle dynamique
une nouvelle dynamique que certains
jeunes voilà peuvent apporter au niveau
des territoires vie donc c'était
volailles à vous soutenez également le
modem soutient alain juppé qui est quand
même une personne d'un certain agent
nettoyant une volonté de se rajeunir
commence à s'expliquer ce que vous avez
aussi vous un certain une certaine
expérience à certains parlent quand pour
justement vous vous défendre au niveau
politique
oui bah alors prenez l'exemple d'alain
juppé pour les mêmes l'exemple de
françois bayrou qui sont
hommes qui sont pas qui disons qu'ils
n'ont pas mon âge mais je pense que le
renouvellement est aussi dans les idées
et est alors juppé françois bayrou
portent tous deux l'idée de
rassemblement
l'idée de réforme de réformer le pays
donc je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
qui est qui n'est pas nouveau mais qui
sont des idées qui ont besoin d'être
d'être mise en avant sur la scène
politique aujourd'hui le modem est droit
dans ses bottes depuis 2007 c'est à dire
que certes nous sommes un parti du
centre et nous le revendiquons mais nous
avons vocation à rassembler les français
parce qu'aujourd'hui il est il est
impossible on va dire d'avoir un
candidat un président qui ne représente
que son électorat ou que son parti
politique
si on prend l'exemple de françois
hollande aujourd'hui françois hollande
se comporte comme en premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il essaye de
faire la synthèse à gauche avec plus ou
moins de succès et aujourd'hui c'est
plus possible de se comporter comme ça
aujourd'hui nous devons avoir des là je
votais large rassemblement d'union et
essayer justement de réformer le pays
cette volonté de justement rajeunir un
petit peu le party des fêtes terrain
andres en lice mais on peut dire au
modem au niveau local et peut-être même
nationale oui alors déjà on a énormément
d'élus de jeunes élus qui se sont
implantés des 2008 et aussi au niveau
des dix mois ci c'est des jeunes élus
c'est à dire que bon c'est des
trentenaires bon c'est ce que ce que
j'appelle en tout cas des jeunes c'est
lui on en a eu d'autres en 2014 et donc
cesser ses émules à ces jeux nous élus
vont continuer à progresser dans la vie
politique
oui ils ont énormément d'idées apporter
défendre les valeurs du centre défendre
les valeurs du modem et oui on compte
sur vous venez donc de villepreux donc
c'est une nouvelle commune de
l'agglomération qui fait maintenant
partie le cas de saint quentin en
yvelines élargie selon vous voilà enfin
que lui proposait aussi en tant que
délégué territorial du modem cedar
gisement est une bonne chose pour vous
pour le modèle wi alors bon
on va pas revenir sur toute la réforme
territoriale je pense qu'elle a été
comme toute réforme territoriale un
petit peu bâclé on avait même
l'impression parfois que ça cet effet
sur un coin de table
nous avons sur la délimitation des
régions on pourrait en dire beaucoup de
choses
par contre nous on a toujours défendu on
a toujours défendu le couple entière
communalité région notamment et je pense
que c'est une bonne chose
alors après on peut discuter du
périmètre de la casse qui il ya de la
nouvelle par dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin
mais maintenant qu'ils avaient fait il
va falloir s'entendre
il va falloir mutualisés pour déjà d'une
faire des économies tout en ayant des
services publics de qualité donc non ici
c'est ainsi cette nouvelle
intercommunalité est porteuse de projets
nous la soutiendrons et michel laugier a
tout notre soutien il le sait justement
pour pour les prochaines années
vous allez justement mener des
initiatives aussi au sein voilà de la
casse qui a apporté des idées du modem
c'est la transition tout à fait alors
aujourd'hui déjà on va se réorganiser au
niveau du modem départemental des
yvelines
nous avions des délégués de
circonscription nous allons avoir des
délégués de territoires qui seront
calquées sur les nouveaux périmètres
intercommunaux
quel est l'objectif l'objectif c'est
justement de doha dire de réintroduire
un peu plus de proximité locale à léo
directement en contact des yvelinois et
être force de proposition donc oui nous
allons travailler sur les compétences
des différentes intercommunalités voir
comment ce qu'on pourrait apporter en
terme de projet et nous demanderons il
nous enverrons nos propositions au
président d internaliser oui au niveau
national le modem a dû x bas parfois du
mal à se faire entendre de loin à peser
dans l'effectif politique c'est la même
problématique au niveau local alors moi
je vais vous renvoyez juste un sondage
récent quand vous voyez le dernier
sondage ifop pour le premier tour
justement de la présidentielle de 2017
vous voyez que françois bayrou est
crédité de 15 à 18% ce qui montre qu'il
ya un socle électoral qui est là qui est
là donc je me dont on n'est peut-être
pas forcément audible sur tous les
sujets mais justement on y travaille on
y travaille notamment au niveau local
dans ce que nous allons faire nous dans
les yvelines c'est réinvestir le terrain
d'ailleurs on l'a fait en hors période
électorale parce que je pense que c'est
important de maîtriser le jeu était à
côté des républicains en cellule et
alors il ya deux choses
il ya des sujets sur lesquels on peut
être d'accord et dans ce cas là on n'a
aucun travail a travaillé avec certains
républicains et avec lui dénie toute
façon moi je suis persuadé que le centre
aura vocation à se recomposer
je sais pas quand exactement mais ce
sera le cas donc aucun problème pour
travailler avec eux
après nous nous avons des thématiques
qui nous sont propres je pense notamment
à l'europe mais aussi d'une certaine
façon mais les républicains parlent un
peu moins d'europe est aujourd'hui oui
c'est une thématique qui va falloir
aborder il va falloir aborder ce que
j'appelle un peu les trois les trois
grands eux c'est-à-dire emploi éducation
et europe on pourrait même on a ajouté
un quatrième qui est celui de l'état
notamment rien juppé qui pour cette idée
d'un état fort dans lequel on est on est
assez d'accord sur ces propositions
et aussi sur tout un volet démocratique
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui si vous
prenez si vous cumulez les voix de
l'extrême gauche de l'extrême droite et
du centre vous avez près d'un français
sur deux qui n'est pas représenté au
parlement
donc nous nous allons continuer aussi à
défendre la proportionnelle françois
hollande s'y était engagé en 2012 il n'a
pas fait si jamais nous avons la chance
d'être au pouvoir
nous ferons j'aimerais revenir sur une
problématique plus local
voilà la fusion ou des îles et des hauts
de seine c'est vraiment une croix note
ce qui nous intéresse en ce moment c'est
une bonne chose pour vous comme
l'agglomération de 50 ans un
verdissement alors sur le projet de
fusion leur faut quand même rappeler que
pour l'instant c'est il ya eu la
création d'un établissement public à
coopération interdépartementale
on parle de la fusion mais c'est pas
encore acté c'est en discussion bon sur
l'objectif je suis pas contre et je
comprends les différer différents
avantages qui peut qu'il peut y avoir à
cette fusion c'est à dire mutualisé
essayer de faire des économies et
essayer de voir quelles compétences on
peut partager ça oui d'accord sur le
principe pourquoi pas après je suis
beaucoup plus sceptique sur la manière
dont les choses ont été menées c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui
rappelez vous pendant et bart les
départementales de 2015 on n'a pas
abordé ce sujet là on n'a pas abordé ce
projet de fusion donc à mon avis les
citoyens les yvelinois ne sont pas du
tout informés sur les avantages et les
inconvénients que cette fusion pourrait
avoir
donc je pense qu'il faut d'abord faire
de la pédagogie sur ce sujet nous allons
essayer de le faire nous-mêmes 78 et sur
un sujet aussi important je pense qu'il
faudra pas passer en force
donc je pense que le référendum local
peut être une bonne solution à cette
question
merci jean baptiste a répondu à la
d'avoir répondu à la question d'avoir
accepté notre invitation tout autre
sujet à présent amateurs de nature ou de
balades insolites vous pouvez également
faire de belles découvertes parfois sans
aller très loin de la ville c'est ce que
propose l'association nature et vous
faire découvrir le patrimoine naturel et
écologique
versailles est ce week-end une dizaine
de paires
nous ont participé à une première
promenade sur le thème des oiseaux d'eau
à la pièce d'eau des suisses
justement des images signées mélanie
motif ils marchent sur les traces des
oiseaux versailles et ou plutôt des
volatiles qui ont élu domicile à la
pièce d'eau des suisses en période
hivernale elle abrite de nombreux
spécimens des espèces que l'association
nature et vous décide de faire découvrir
aux ornithologues en herbe armés de
jumelles et de chaussures de marche
je sais qu'ils sont présents d'autres
personnes faisant remarquer aussi le
fuligule morillon et le fuligule milouin
ce sont des espèces de canards j'y
connais rien en fait je les connais pas
du tout et ça m'intéresse de pouvoir les
reconnaître un petit peu c'est très
intéressant ça permet de mettre des noms
sur les
mes animaux qu'on voit hélas les oiseaux
et puis d'apprendre un peu leurs moeurs
comprendre un peu mieux fuligules grèbes
huppés ou signe des oiseaux d'eau
écologiquement dépendant des milieux
humides
l'association a décidé de les faire
connaître grâce à cette promenade d'une
heure et demie une initiative qu'elle
conduit pour la première fois les deux
objectifs de l'association sont
effectivement de sensibiliser les gens à
la protection d'environnement
c'est quelque chose qui nous touche qui
nous touche beaucoup et puis la deuxième
chose c'est de faire découvrir aux
nouveaux participants qu'à côté de chez
eux ou en bas de chez eux il y à des
espèces qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
reconnaître et qui ont des choses à nous
apprendre
un de nos objectifs aussi ces deux
monstres gentils qu'ils ont de quoi
s'émerveiller autour d'eux mêmes des
espèces qui sont très commune finalement
on peut retrouver cet émerveillement
juste en ouvrant les yeux
en observant ce qui nous entoure le
patrimoine naturel de versailles enfin
révélé prochaine balade programmé par
l'association le 23 avril au départ de
la cathédrale saint louis
là où nichent le faucon crécerelle une
autre espèce méconnu et nous entamons la
deuxième semaine de vacances pour la
zone c les lieux touristiques multiplie
les activités notamment à destination
des enfants à la laiterie de la reine à
rambouillet les équipes proposent de
découvrir le lieu à travers les cinq
sens
regardez ce reportage ce n'est mélanie
poquet elle adore s'amuser elle adore
s'occuper des animaux et donc son mari
le roi louis saez en personne a décidé
de lui offrir ici à rambouillet dans son
domaine une magnifique laiteries les
kits explication historique pour ces
enfants de 7 à 12 ans avant de se lancer
dans l'aventuré
pendant ses vacances la laiterie de la
reine acheté par louis saez en 1783
devient un espace de jeux pour les plus
jeunes leur défi apprendre à travers les
cinq sens
pourquoi avoir choisi les sens parce que
ici quand marie antoinette elles
venaient
on peut dire vraiment que tous ses sens
étaient en alerte on avait ces animaux
qui étaient là les odeurs des produits
laitiers etc des choses qu'aujourd'hui
on a complètement disparu parce qu on
est vraiment dans un monument à part
entière qui a perdu finalement son âme
identifié un médaillon simplement le
touchant ou encore reconnaître un
produit laitier au goût des épreuves
parfois un peu compliqué comme ce
parcours à la règle j'avais les yeux
bandés et j'ai dû j'ai dû écouter
quelqu'un pour me guider dans un dans un
circuit et il y avait quelqu'un d'autre
qui me disent l inverse
c'est bien c'est marrant et puis j'aime
bien
après tous ces efforts un peu de repos
bien mérité dans la salle fraîcheur de
marie-antoinette la laiterie de la reine
accueille les enfants de 3 à 12 ans les
mercredis jeudis vendredis et samedis
jusqu'au 7 mars prochain et nous aurons
une page sports à présent football
américain vont jouer ce week-end la
troisième journée du championnat élite
l'équivalent de la première division
ce samedi les templiers d'elancourt ont
été terrassés sur leur terrain par les
dauphins de nice le score 33 à 13 résumé
du match avec michael et demi d'euros ml
à l'époque et un match à vite oublier
pour les templiers d'elancourt ce samedi
les élans courtois se sont fait
submerger sur leur terrain par les
dauphins de nice à l'occasion de la 3e
journée du championnat élite
le score est sévère 33 13 les dauphins
sont pas venus ici de nice
pour faire un match nul ou perd deux
matches ils sont venus ils étaient
motivés
c'est une équipe explosive ils n'ont pas
beaucoup de joueurs donc il joue sur
intensité et il joue ensemble on s'est
pas réveillé dans les cinq minutes qu'a
eu cinq actions on prend des essais donc
après c'est dur de revenir
c'est une bonne équipe il faut le
respecter mais nous on a on arrêtait
plein d'occasions on a beaucoup plus de
talent ils veulent potentiel que ce
disque on a montré ce sens
après cette contre-performance les
templiers pour à la quatrième place du
classement avec un bilan de deux
défaites et victoires pour expliquer ce
début de saison ou de 80 les cadres pour
être le manque d'assiduité aux
entraînements on joue comme on
s'entraîne et dernièrement on a pas fait
des supers entraînements et ça se voit
sur le terrain
si on veut performer nous aimons
l'entraînement plus de discipline ce cas
en devenir prochain match pour les
templiers d'elancourt le dimanche 13
mars sur le terrain des cougars de
saint-ouen-l'aumône champion de france
2015 et invaincus depuis 17 matches et
les templiers d'elancourt peut-être
bientôt connue dans le monde entier en
tout cas aux états unis elles ont reçu
la semaine dernière la visite d'une
équipe de tournage américaine la société
de production de podium composé de
quatre personnes est venue visiter et
filmé pendant cinq jours les îles ans
pour toi pour réaliser un documentaire
sur l'émergence du football américain en
europe
on écoute tout de suite oui poële le
cofondateur de l'entreprise
il est au micro de mélanie popov la
ligue française est très compétitive et
à la grandit très rapidement nous avons
voulu couvrir les templiers parce que
c'est une petite ville avec de bons
joueurs un bon coach et nous pensons
qu'ils vont avoir beaucoup de succès
c'est non et l'équipe de tournage posera
également sa caméra au flash de la
courneuve et sur les terrains des
cougars de saint-ouen-l'aumône avant
d'aller en suisse
le documentaire sera mis en ligne sur le
site qui s'affiche en ce moment en bas
de votre écran aucune date de diffusion
n'a été communiqué mais nous vous
tiendrons bien sûr au courant
et enfin c'est une discipline peu
médiatisée pourtant elle compterait près
de 60000 pratiquants sur le territoire
l'aïkido est un art martial
fondé au début des années 1900 au japon
allie technique physique mentale et
spirituelle aux clayes-sous-bois geraldo
de carvalho et professeur d'aïkido
depuis septembre 2015
il fait
et c'est parti pardon des vins français
à être 6e dan regardez ce portrait signé
camille lambert une technique imparable
pour déséquilibrer son adversaire
geraldo l'enseigne à ses élèves depuis
1998 aujourd'hui il fait partie des
trois professeurs yvelinois être 6e dan
dans cette discipline
cette distinction dont la tribu à deux
ingrédients travail et passion faut être
passionné à la base et la passion a mano
ce résultat est sans s'y attend d'eux
sans faire aucune demande de tous les
grades que j'ai passé ces les
professeurs qui m'ont présenté en france
ils sont une vingtaine à avoir obtenu ce
grade
alliant technique de défense
enseignements spirituels l'aïkido est
basé principalement sur leskiw
l'objectif d amorcer l'agression sans
attaquer et être en harmonie avec son
adversaire
c'est basé uniquement par les
déplacements juste au moment où juste
j'ai toujours aimé le rôle de hockey
celui qui subit la technique qui pour
moi est un grand artiste qu'il est
dirigé par celui qui fait la technique
mais en même temps il faut qu ils
vraiment qu'ils soient sur la même
longueur d'onde
des combattants en jupe une image qui a
marqué geraldo quand il a découvert
l'aïkido dans les années 70 sa passion
pour cette philosophie est né à
l'adolescence avec les films d'arts
martiaux il y avait un téléfilm qui
passait à la télévision je me rappelle
cette semaine le samedi après midi qui
s'appelait kung fu avec david carradine
et c'est un film qui était magnifique
la conception de sa philosophie quand il
était tout jeune quand il était au
monastère
est ce que m peau vivait à l'instant qui
a porté le coup fatal à son meurtrier
amoureux du japon un des arts martiaux
geraldo s'est également lancé dans le
karaté depuis six ans mais pour lui
quelle que soit la discipline
il s'agit d'une grande et même famille
et c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis tout de
suite vous avez rendez vous avec michael
et demi d'euros pour le 7-8 sport et les
résultats sportifs du week-end au
programme du football américain du
basket féminin avec notamment la
victoire des filles du club
le chesnay versailles je vous retrouve
demain pour une nouvelle édition du
journal je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée